what really impressed me about this man
was um he told me the name of the
gentleman I was dating at the time
without any use of anything and he told
me the name of the psychic that I was
going to wow which I was blown away
nobody had ever done I thought this is
what I was looking for this is what the
reality I was looking for it's like
they're they're they're doing something
that they can buy your okay your faith
basically in that thing it is
a
welcome to another episode of LED live
everyone we are glad that you can join
us this week we have a guest with us
today this is Marisol so welcome Marisol
for coming thank you for having me and
she is going to talk to us about
Voodoo and its connections to
Catholicism actually you've done a fair
amount of research and written a book M
and so I'm sure we'll hear more about
that at the end but um you've come to
share with us and we're I guess we're
going to do a Bible study aren't we yeah
in Jeremiah okay very cool so how did
you grow up did you grow up Christian
did you grow up Catholic did you grow up
in Voodoo was it a combination of all
three I grew up in the Catholic Church
my dad was Catholic your dad was
Catholic okay and so how long did that
last in your life like at some point you
got older and you said walk away yes
until I was 18 and I left my home mhm um
and to live on my own I went to the
Catholic Church the very last time when
I was 18 I witnessed everybody speaking
and talking when the priest was speaking
and I just saw no faith there so I knew
I knew it wasn't for me and I left and I
never went back till this day I've never
gone into a Catholic church again and
did you leave just because you're 18 I'm
done with home or you're like going off
to school or you just I was searching
for something you were searching I
didn't know what it was I didn't know
who it was but I was searching at a
young age for God and I didn't know it
was God I was looking for H all right
yeah so at what point did you find how
long did you search what when did you
find what you were looking for it was a
long journey long I started when I was
18 and I left the Catholic Church um
after I left the Catholic church I went
to a Pentecostal church because it was
near the area and I didn't have any
guidance my mother lived in New York my
dad was a Catholic and I didn't know any
anything about the Bible or what the
Bible said um so I went to the
Pentecostal church and I saw how happy
they were and how they worshiped you
know with music and you can clap and you
can sing and sing to God the way you
wanted to so that was kind of like a a
breakthrough for me and I went and I got
baptized and I got saved I thought I got
saved at that moment and I accepted
Jesus and I was like 29 years old and I
already had a daughter and I was married
at that that time oh wow so you're
looking at you know 11 years down the
line yes for all of this to transpire
what did you do in between
time um just kind of church hopping did
you look at other religions I didn't I
didn't go into anything didn't go into
anything no I I if I went I went to the
Pentecostal Church MH and it wasn't
until I had my daughter that I started
searching really again so at 18 I was
looking for something or someone I
didn't know was Jesus Christ but I know
now that it was Jesus but um at that
time I didn't I had no clue what I was
looking for I was looking for truth
really I think now that I looked back I
was looking for truth of some kind some
kind of reality to hit me and so I
started with the Pentecostal church and
they didn't really offer any type of
Bible study there um so I really didn't
go back and then um when I was growing
up my dad married a a woman who was from
Ecuador he was he's from Ecuador and um
she was into uh going to psychics and
stuff okay she would take baths with
leaves that I would see her you know
doing and and I just remember her always
talking about this Indian man that she
used to go see in South America and he
would tell her things so um I didn't do
it at that time but I wanted you know
when I wanted to know something about
the future I started going to psychics
when I got older oh interesting oh wow
did it did it feel wrong at first it
really didn't interesting M I wasn't
saved at that time so I didn't I
couldn't see wrong from right at that
moment did it seem like you were getting
some information that was useful at the
time uh I I thought it was useful um you
know they don't really tell you much
yeah kind of vague yeah it's very vague
they say you're going to meet this one
guy and you know you're going to work
for him is what she told me you're going
to like
food it was very vague yeah very vague
and so it kind of you know kind of
pressed me at the moment and um so I my
search continued until I was in I moved
to Aventura Florida and I'm looking at
this one Latin uh newspaper like a
classified ad and um it said Papa Raul
Voodoo and I thought wow I've never been
to one of these so let me go to this one
I called immediately with no fear I was
really young and dumb at the time and um
and I made an appointment to see
him and that's when it that's when
everything really started to happen wow
yeah so give us a little bit of like um
what what what is voodoo I mean what do
they do I mean I I have this image in my
head of them you know like running
around with chickens with no head or
something but is it is it like that you
know I never I never witnessed that but
it they do do um animal sacrifice they
don't believe in Jesus so they do do uh
animal sacrifices and it is a religion
that started in Africa um in Benin
Africa which is actually called
Dome now and if you break down the word
Dome it means Dan's home Dan home like
the tribe of Dan and the tribe of Dan
they're not they're not one of the part
of the 144,000 that are saved in the end
because of their idolatry so if you look
up the history of voodoo in Benin it'll
tell you they actually say they are from
the tribe of Dan oh
interesting fascinating yeah so I I
learned that later hm but this man that
I went to um when I finally went to go
see him he had a a big bull on the on
his back of his
wall at that time I didn't know it that
was Bale but now I do so I mean all the
signs were there that I should have
walked out but I
didn't and this is before your daughter
this was no I already had my daughter so
you had your daughter I was 33 at the
time at this point okay searching it's
my search continued yeah it's
interesting how when you have a kid you
will start to
evaluate what life is about or what
you're doing with your life or your
life's choices I don't know if you went
through that did you go through that yes
yeah so I know you went through that I
went through that you went through that
everybody and it doesn't seem to
matter it doesn't seem to matter what
religion people are in or what what you
know or if they have no religion at all
it seems like they will
evaluate you know they understand that
there's a responsibility there and it's
like
I'm responsible now for this other whole
other life like right what am I going to
teach them what am I going to you know
how are we going to do this thing and so
yeah fascinating okay so you're
searching you're 33 at this point you go
to a voodoo priest a voodoo priest okay
how far into this did you get and he's
called Papa Raul which means father in
Spanish so he was like a Godfather same
name that they call the Catholic the
father they call God
yeah um so uh so I went to see him and
um he had a reading in the back of his
room he had a a reading room and so when
I walked in and he's an artist as well
and he had
painted on his wall I saw a picture that
he painted of Adam and Eve in the garden
which was beautiful by the way but I
just found it so odd that he had that
painting on his wall and I asked him
about it I said where did you get that
and he said that he painted it himself
wow so I'm in the I walk in the back of
the room and then I see it's dark and he
has uh one small little table in the
middle of the room and this round thing
with sand on it and um some shells and
that's how he did his readings but what
really impressed me about this man was
um that he he told me the name of the
gentleman I was dating at the time
without any use of anything and he told
me the name of the psychic that I was
going to wow which I was blown away
nobody had ever done that I thought this
is what I was looking for this is what
the reality I was looking for it's like
they're they're they're doing something
that they can buy your okay your faith
basically in that thing it is a bit
exactly exactly if you know this what
else do you know and then it just kind
of feeds you in yes and I asked him how
do you know that he said that the that
the dead speak to him yeah which which I
mean I mean no doubt the spirits are
probably talking to each other like oh
yeah this who she's going visiting
necromancy it's in the Bible God's
against it I didn't know that had I read
my Bible none of that would have
happened to me but that's what happened
at the moment M okay so you're impressed
MH how far down this rabbit hole do you
go okay so he said that um uh that I
should become one of them and um I said
okay he said it cost
$5,000 and I told him to do what got
initiated got to pay to play initiated
yes so that was your first meeting that
was my first meeting that you just tell
her the whole the whole stuff like okay
you want to be like this you this is how
he was recruiting like a he was
recruiting people wow so do you know
anything about Voodoo or just saw never
so you just you you were searching and
you you saw like okay Voodoo Papa rul
yeah and you say I'm going to call this
guy yes I mean just interesting just
from the outside I mean that seems like
that's a pretty good racket
but right I it's like well what's the
$5,000 for you know it's like you get
blessing or what I mean it's like I
don't know I'm I'm I'm being a little
bit um I don't know I'm being a little
bit humorous but it's it's like you know
growing up in Christianity God doesn't
work that way it's not like you know if
you just give me enough
money in fact when when when um was it
uh
elus uh that approached Paul and he's
like you know how much does it cost like
I want to cast out demons too and Paul's
like you're going to walk around blind
for a year he's like you know how dare
you try to buy the spirit of God Amen
Simon was it Simon Simon was it Simon it
Simon I was thinking it was elus but
okay yeah either way it was it was
somebody who who wanted that power and
he's like no no no this cannot be bought
so it's when you see other things and
it's like well you know you can have
this it's going to cost you a little bit
you know because it already costs you
right so at its core what are they what
are they sort of promoting that you're
doing in Voodoo is it just access to the
spirit world is that kind of what
they're pushing yeah uh access to the
spirit the spirit world and um whatever
you want it's whatever you want you have
to pay the voodoo priest to do whatever
it is you want if you want a boyfriend
additional yes
additional if you want a boyfriend they
can get you a boyfriend if there's a
certain boyfriend that you want you pay
them to get you that boy that that man
or that girl there's men that go to them
he even told me there's Jewish people
that go to him to see him W oh wow wow
interesting and his story in this man's
testimony he told me that um he lived in
New York when in 1980 and the spirits
took over his body H and told him to
move from New York and to divorce the
woman he was with and to move to Miami
he lives in Miami
and so they do what the spirit's telling
to do and he told me that um that he was
drinking and doing things that weren't
right at the time when this entity took
over his body and um that that's
probably why it happened to him he
thinks it's a greater he told me he
thought it was the greatest religion in
the world but I mean I didn't I don't
believe that Jesus Christ saved me and
that's right there's no one better than
him and no one more powerful than him
and I didn't know it at the time I know
it now amen yeah so how did you get
pulled out of that okay so he tells me
at some point so the $5,000 he tells me
the cost $ 5,000 I told him I don't have
it he said you could pay me $300 a month
so it took three years for me to pay him
wow so you did pay him I did pay him wow
wow never got my money back but he I did
pay him and then at the end of the three
years one of the requirement was that I
had to go see one of the initiation
ceremonies so I went to go see that and
I see a girl become completely possessed
and I knew right then that that wasn't
for me yeah I hadn't seen it up close
yeah you know they just he never showed
me anything he never taught me anything
I never got
initiated um so when I saw that ceremony
it scared me so much I totally went the
other direction wow and never went back
to a psychic I never I never even
thought of any going that route ever
again and um my friend who was a
Christian invited me one afternoon to go
out like we used to and and um we were
driving by a church and he said stop
there so we stopped there and the
preacher was talking about um how God
tries to reach us through preachers and
he had a message of like anger and I was
really angry at that time because I was
really searching for something and I
thought I had found it but that wasn't
it so the one I was really searching for
was Jesus Christ I just didn't know it
and so I got baptized in the ocean with
like 500 other believers that day and
like two weeks after that wow and I
accepted Jesus as my Lord and Savior and
wow my life completely did a 360 wow in
the better Direction yeah yeah and I
knew that's what I was looking for I
knew that's who it was yeah so so you
left the voodoo never never returned
back and then um you know were you fully
comprehending when you when you chose to
go and seek out Jesus were you fully
comprehending like that was from the
devil Voodoo did it take time to
understand that after I saw that
ceremony I knew for sure they were they
were from the Demonic Realm M so for how
long you were doing Voodoo um paying him
3 years MH the 300 a month but I didn't
practice it Okay I didn't learn anything
he didn't teach me anything there was no
spells he taught me I didn't learn any
of it and I never became initiated
there's other people's testimonies that
I hear that that they actually were you
know involved in it and they learned
stuff I never learned anything so is
that because you hadn't paid in full yet
so they weren't going to teach you
anything till you paid in full no I
don't I don't know to be honest with you
that's such a racket I'm glad I didn't
learn yeah I'm just like that's that's
that's pretty amazing and that's a low
amount if you hear other testimonies
from other people who've come out of it
they paid 20 and 30,000 wow yeah
witchcraft stuff and S and also it's
very expensive and it depends what kind
of favor you want to do because they
want the milk of this of the this you
know it's very expensive right and and
yeah yes even in the book of act you
know all the books that were uh when
they found Jesus they accept Jesus and
they say okay we need to burn those
books and they were like a lot of money
back yeah yeah it's not like books were
hugely common yeah exactly and and you
didn't buy a book for it to just sit on
the Shelf so I'm just you know as you're
talking about this and I'm I'm thinking
through all this I'm like I'm reminded
of that song you know which song I'm
thinking of no I Put a Spell on You oh
yeah oh you're right yeah if you watch
the old actual real version of that song
um from the guy's like it's like black
and white like looks like at the very
beginning stages of of of film and video
and I mean he's like completely
possessed yeah the song sitting there
thinking about how you know people can
go they can ask they can pay it's like
and then you have this song it's like I
Put a Spell on you but people actually
do that yeah yeah they do I Put A Spell
On You
and now you're
mine you can't stop the things I
do I ain't
liy no
no hey Max great show cover your ears I
put a fail on you I'm glad you left just
so am I you saw the experence I was like
I'm out of here oh it's hor it was
horrible so you left all of that found
Jesus I'm sure you got into a a
Christian believing body yes uh
fellowshipping studying worshiping
together but at some point in your life
you're probably
reflecting and saying the things I saw
over here and the things I grew up with
there's a lot of similarities I found
that the saints that they worship in
Catholicism are exactly the same deities
that are woried in Sania and Voodoo just
given different names which is not
really the uncommon of an idea because
you I've seen quotes where you know
essentially Peter and and St Peter's
pilica is really older that statue is
older than Peter right and so it's like
you know they had adopted Greek and
Roman deities and just renamed them as
Saints so it's not it's not a different
Concept in what's already going on right
yeah it you know um Catholicism it
doesn't doesn't Catholic just mean
universal yes so they were kind of
taking a lot of ideas and as they began
to grow and they were spreading out into
different cultures they were like okay
how can we get this culture on board
with what we're doing well we'll just
call it this other thing and then we'll
take on their religious practices but to
soak it up into the to the larger body
and that's what yeah that's what I've
heard why we have a lot of the the you
know the dates and the things that
things are celebrated and you know a lot
of that comes from just a a renaming
right another religion and calling it
Christian right yeah they hijacked
Christianity as what what they did
pretty much because they till this day
they still they call themselves
Christian yeah so fascinating so in
santoria all the same people yes just
different names different names and
santoria is like what like a voodoo type
of Catholicism it is a child religion of
voodoo interesting Voodoo is the more
like prominent one in Africa and um it's
in a different it's San is from the Yuba
area and Voodoo is in from the Benin
area in Africa so they're just two
different locations so they're named
differently but from what I remember
when I was in it it's it's a lesser form
of voodoo
mhm they don't have as many gods as the
voodoo the voodoo religion has tons of
gods San only has seven H oh yeah so do
do they consider themselves Catholics
still the ones that practice Sania is
that a branch of Catholicism so to say
um they totally different I think it's I
think they don't see it as Catholicism
but they do know like Sania priests know
that it's the same exact thing MH
actually on my website I have an
interview that I did with a santoria
priest and I had just met him and with
no effort at all he named off the names
of the santoria priests and their
Catholic counterparts oh wow so they
don't practice it together but they know
it's the same thing a lot of Latin
people know it's the same it's the same
thing MH the American Catholicism the
American Catholics don't know it MH but
the Latin ones I think they kind of see
it mhm
H yeah it's very easy to identify
navigate with the S because I mean it's
kind of like they go to uh the mass and
they do a lot of few things festivals of
this you know so it's been kind of like
okay you want to come come over here to
do a little practice of some right so
he's oh yeah it's not too bad I mean
that is and the beginning of some like a
wishcraft and all this you know together
yes and it santoria just means Saint
worship which is the same thing in
Catholic that's what you do worshiping
Saints
right I mean they pray to the Saints
right yeah the Bible's very specific on
you know like you know you should have
no worship whatsoever other than him
yeah amen yep God is only the one to be
worshiped amen if you just take the
example of Jesus Jesus was holy only
just praying to the Father in Heaven yes
he did he didn't even call Mary Mother
he called her woman interesting on
purpose because he knew what was going
to happen in the future yes m
what else did you find um that's pretty
much the biggest thing that I found uh
that God wanted me to just let people
know
that it's the same religion just hidden
I guess so that people would be deceived
into practicing it so what other
similarities I mean so we we you see
like there's you know the Saints but
named differently what other
similarities did you discover between
the two their feast days are the same
like the saints that
the days of that they worship the the
feast days in Catholicism are the same
as the feast days of the Saints in
santoria and in Voodoo oh wow let me
tell you you know I came from Mexico
right 20 plus years and my first
Eastern have a good time with bunnies
and chocolates and all stuff and my uh
my cousin Mary with two beautiful kids
and he told me like hey we going to go
to to celebr bread um Sunday Easter
Sunday um we're going to do some eggs
and and candy and you know rabbits and
all stuff and I'm like for what and I
said no it's a it's the celebration for
you know for uh you know Easter Easter
Sunday you know resurrection of Jesus
Christ right and I'm like rabbit and
Jesus Christ chocolate what are you
talking about to do one with the other
the oh no but this is for for the
children so we're going to do it early
in the morning or before we go to church
or maybe after church the service we're
going to do this with kids and
everything and I was
like I mean even though in that time I
was one foot in the church and one foot
in the world and I was like this is
crazy bro I mean this is not connection
whatsoever like this is this is Pagan
it's Pagan and I even not even
researched that you know because I knew
some background and and told me was not
it's just it's just how we do here in
America I was like right on in Mexico we
don't do that I mean if you celebrating
Jesus Christ or you just celebrating
this but now you're going to put it all
these things together right and later on
I found out that churches they do this
kind of service I was like what he said
yeah after the service we need to get
the children outside the church eggs
yeah I was like wow yeah but that was
that was my first experience my first
year I was like well e Easter is East
it's for the East the sun rises in the
East and so that's why they call it
Easter but the people don't know what
about uh iar yeah the sun they worship
the Sun the goddess of the fertility
right it's all basis their their
Foundation is in paganism they were
witches they created the church to hide
what they were doing and that's who the
Catholic church is today that's what God
told me that's what Jesus showed me
throughout all of this so that's why
they're found foundations are all Pagan
H okay so you've got Saints you've got
holidays mhm what else the the colors
they use for their Saints are also the
same okay um so just in the the way that
they dress and things like that the
offerings are the same the offerings are
same you know you light a candle you
give a flower you leave money it's all
the same because the Virgin Mary
orup Mexico uh
she likes I mean in the pictures you see
flowers to the flowers ju Diego the
Indian guy you know right and so there
flowers there that's an offering yeah I
think you have some pictures don't you I
do for us to look at yes I'll show you
some similarities that I
found this is a Catholic Altar believe
it or not in a Catholic Church that I
found and um is a spread it's a spread
of fruit and the cake and the bowls that
you see are the different
Saints and they all have a different
each bowl is a different Saint different
color uhhuh never see that before this
is in a Catholic Church I think in the
Philippines oh
okay and then this is the voodoo altar
as you could see they got the fruits the
sun you see that sun a lot in in some
Catholic church it's the same thing in
Voodoo they smoke cigars also which is
another offering to these gods and this
is actually Pro it's called prostration
in the Catholic church it's kind of like
an initiation and then that's in the
Catholic church and this is in Voodoo
they do the same thing why are they lay
laying face down that's when the spirits
are entering their body that's crazy
yeah when when uh nuns wants to become a
nun they lay down like that and it's
kind of like down really yeah what and
also they said that you're going to get
married with Jesus Christ yeah and
that's why maybe talking about the the
spirit that get that's what they tell
them but it's not Mar that's not Jesus
they're marrying yeah it's so
fascinating because it's just it's it's
like a counterfeit right because there
are times in the Bible where you find
people going prostrate before the Lord
you know David did that he's like
totally you know like laid out I think
Daniel did it too it's like it's an act
of yeah an act of submission and act of
worship so it's fascinating that you you
know devil can't think of anything
he duplicates everything God has
everything yeah and this is the Pope the
three- tiered crown of the Pope and I
just had discovered how coincidental in
the occult they use the tarot cards and
if you see it says leap the P it's got
the same exact three- tiered crown and
and he has that thing that looks like
you know what they what they used to
walk around with yeah
interesting that is interesting and this
is called a laet in Voodoo uh it's
called a head washing in English laed is
in French and um this is the first level
of initiation into Voodoo this is a
Catholic Church picture it's not not an
immersion it's just a sprinkling
basically but what they do in Voodoo is
they're seating a one of their spirits
on top of that baby's head right now and
the baby doesn't know it and the parents
don't know it wow but that picture you
said is in in the Catholic church that's
a Catholic Church picture um Voodoo
service she's got another one watch and
this is a voodoo a voodo head washing oh
wow so what I'm saying is that it's the
same exact thing they're they're putting
a spirit on this guy's head and they're
doing the same thing to the child only
the parents don't know if they knew they
wouldn't get they wouldn't have their
baby anywhere near that
church very kind say this is just um an
image of scarlet and purple and I think
that's really interesting that the Bible
uses that in Revelation of scarlet and
purple and it's
like color combination that they're
using to identify Babylon you what I
mean isn't that fascinating and Babylon
is just spiritual confusion so what
you're what you're witnessing is just an
amalgamation of confused religious
practices all jumbled together y yeah
wow I mean the Bible is so accurate you
know what I mean and what's crazy is
it's like Satan looks at the Bible so
don't you think he'd be like oh well
that's calling me out right there so I'm
going to make him wear you know green or
something right plays into it same thing
yeah it's like the thing is that they
don't read the Bible they don't read it
they don't tell them like I you go read
the Bible or something like that no they
all have their own books and everything
they're told that the Bible is not for
today and that they can't understand it
it's the same with the Mormons you get
into a conversation and they say well
the Bible's been tinkered with so the
Book of Mormon is much more true there a
new light yeah more pure and if they
only knew this is just a picture I took
of the entrance of a shrine in Miami
Florida called
laita and um here they
have it
says in English that
means to Jesus Through Mary through Mary
oh wow which we know that's not the case
it's Jesus is the only mediator what
about the rest of it oh it says Unity uh
K like charity unites us which is
interesting that they would use the the
idea of love you know what I mean cuz I
mean that's really what what God's
government is based on right love their
their love is is is not a proper picture
of it because if you are especially in
Voodoo if you are um saying I want this
person to do what I want them to do I'm
not caring about their feelings or what
they're doing I'm trying to force them
into my way of thinking that's not
necessarily love right if you're like I
want this person to love me and they
don't want to do that then then it's
like that's forceful which is not the
definition of love anything that tries
to bend another person's will to your
will is witchcraft so yeah
and this is um The Sacred Heart of Mary
image in the Catholic church where it
has the daggers in the heart seven
daggers mhm now did that come about um
simply because um when Jesus um was
being dedicated um Simeon yeah Simeon
and he talks about you know like sword
will pierce through her heart is that
kind of where they're getting this from
I'm assuming that that's where they're
where they got it from yeah and also
Jesus has a a picture
[Music]
yes it's all images the Bible tells us
not to make images of anything and he
says it for a reason so all of this is
just tools and tactics that the the
devil has put together to trick people
is there a story behind the black and
the white like why they we why are they
dressing in black and white um well in
the voodoo religion there's two two
rights just like there is in Catholicism
there's the rad right in Voodoo and the
pet right the rad wear white and the
Petro wear black and then in in
Catholicism you've got the white Pope
and the black pope the black pope wears
black and he handles all the darker
things of the ministry and the white
Pope wears white and he handles all the
communication and all the members and he
deals with the public and all that so
it's the same exact thing and this is
the the Mary in Catholicism with the
seven with the daggers and the heart and
this is the one in Voodoo wow in voodoo
she's called a fra I mean even even
wearing the same same garment over her
head yes and you know the white the in
this case not black but you know blue
and the Little M emblem mhm is for this
one this entity she in the Bible she's
actually named in Jeremiah 13:18 it says
say unto the king and to the queen
humble yourself sit down for your
principality shall come down even the
crown of your glory and this is Jeremiah
speaking to the Israelites about their
idolatry and their worship of the Queen
of Heaven so that's the Queen of Heaven
that they worship this one right here
and she's a principality in the Demonic
realm she is nowhere near anywhere near
the Mary the mother of Jesus and I have
proof of that because you can read the
book of Jeremiah 44 where he's telling
the Israelites not to worship the Queen
of Heaven and what's going to happen to
them if they do and God's anger and his
wrath came down upon them they were
scattered out into the world because
they didn't listen to Jeremiah's um
prophecy against them it's fascinating
too because in in in Revelation you see
that similar type
description in um Verse 18 speaking of
this in time apostate system it says in
the measure uh this verse in the measure
that she glorified herself and live
luxuriously in the same measure give her
torment and sorrow for she says in her
heart I sit as Queen and am no Widow and
will not see sorrow yes I have found
that uh by worshiping her you get you
have curses that come upon you and one
of them is
poverty and um there are some images of
Mary where she's crying and that's
because the people who serve her she
puts them through relationship after
relationship after relationship after
relationship that causes them to have
sorrow and they cry and so
um the curses that God told the
Israelites that they were going to have
upon them mostly were that he was going
to scatter them and that's exactly what
happened to them it's very interesting
what you're saying about poverty because
poverty yes she brings poverty yeah
because I don't know I just put things
together um uh you know Latin Community
you know all the countries Mexico Cuba
you know Haiti is not but you
know uh but you see in the dark ages and
then in the 1800s when the when the
Bible people were reading more the Bible
That's you the Bible is you know it's a
lamp to my feet it's going to be shining
in the whole way walking so the thing is
that when you bring when you start
reading the word of God is the
brightness of life you know Freedom life
you know and everything and look at the
country I
mean I mean United States the country of
you know Christian country you know we
put it that way but how it started you
know people had come and say you know we
want to worship God you know the Bible
you know stuff like that so we see in
the beginning of the 1900s so we see
that uh people were reading more the
Bible and that all these people they
were creating inventions and you know
more technology was growing and
everything so it bring yes Prosperity
you know bless is the nation who's God
who makes God his God yes yeh their God
Amen yeah on the contrary if you worship
the Pagan deities the Bible in Jeremiah
actually States the curses he told them
he would give them were drunkenness
they'll fight with one another and kill
each other to in their drunken State no
pity or Mercy will be given to them from
Yahweh the father unless they repent
they'll be H held captive in their own
land and he will scatter them to a
country they do not
know it's really not I mean God isn't
really saying anything different to them
than he didn't say in Deuteronomy you
know right um I've been listening
through Deuteronomy this month and um
you know even just in the earliest
chapter or chapters you listen to the
way it's it's phrase like this is in
chapter 4 surely I have taught you
statutes and judgments just as the Lord
my God commanded me that you should act
according to them in the land which you
go to possess therefore be careful to
observe them for this is your wisdom and
your understanding in the sight of the
peoples who will hear all these statutes
and say surely this great nation is wise
and understanding people he's he's
showing them like look your blessing is
going to come when you do the things
that I've counseled you to
do and you know he just keeps going on
and on talking about how if you when you
do this a blessing will come but if
you're going to depart from this there's
a whole bunch of things that are going
to happen have you read through
Deuteronomy same thing all the things
that that God said if you depart will
happen they all happened y Israelite
people went through all that what is the
verse in Jeremiah it says I know I have
the plans for you it plans for you to
prosper 2911 that was said in Jeremiah
right there you know yes yeah if if we
worship you know like you know Saints
idols and all stuff uh Babylon you know
confusion right yes but also it comes
with the word corruption mhm because
those politics and then you come with um
you know Catholic you know the faith and
you know the church and state you know
putting all right you bring corruption
right
uh in Mexico it was a it was a president
Benito hes that he was like everybody
loved that guy like one of the best
right in the 1800s why one of the
biggest thing that he did is because in
that time uh the Catholics will say you
know what I'm going to tell you what to
do kind of like same thing while it was
in Europe yeah right so they want to
bring that thing to to Mexico and that
President say no we're going to
separate church and state you need to
tell me what to do you need to you know
you know go to church and you tell there
but here are going to run how I run it
right so it was a separation of that so
that was a huge movement that it was
separated so it was it was that's how it
should be it should be separated
separated but when I you United and
underground like you were saying like
Okay black pop white pop and all this
stuff that huge word is corruption and
how you want to keep their citizens
right you all you got to do is look at
history I mean it's amazing how many
nations went through this like you know
you see probably one of the Prime
examples is the country of France right
you have the Dark Ages and then they're
like okay reject Catholicism reject
Christianity reject all of that stuff
they went totally the other way and then
you watch country after country they
almost all go through this in Europe
they have a
revolution right and it's like they have
this time of godlessness and rebellion
and and Revolt and Civil War and and you
know what it did it it was like as bad
or worse as what they were already going
right and so it's like you know the
devil's just got them going back and
forth between like a ping pong ball
between two two things and one is as bad
as the other one you know
but what was missing all of out of it
was God they didn't have God in any of
it and he's just trying to keep them
away from God going from one extreme to
the other yeah and as soon as they
started Landing or started reading the
Bible and stuff I mean you look at how
those Nations changed and how they
blossomed and how they grew in all kinds
of
ways you see a difference of uh Dr
Dominican Republic and Haiti right the
same island it was divided but over here
said no we want all the voodoo and
Witchcraft and everything but the other
one is like Christianity right cath I
mean I think was more Catholic but it
was more open to um
protestantism so you see the the two
lands divided in two different things
you know prosperity and the other ones
not yeah yeah and there's actually
several articles that um Scholars have
written and college students have
written
about um you know people who have pract
the in New Orleans there was another
article I read of a girl who did a a
paper on it and it it was called um
Catholic by day Voodoo by Night H and
she talks about the same exact thing W
so even in Haiti and in New Orleans they
know it's the same actually Catholicism
in Voodoo in Haiti or in New Orleans are
practice together the pope uh bowing to
the black Madonna yeah so so in every
culture we've kind of brought this up on
our show over over um a few times um
each culture has this story of a woman
that has a baby that's going to be the
savior of the Earth right and a lot of
those things predate Christ but what
people don't think about is where that
actually came from Garden of Eden you
know that was told to Adam and Eve while
God and Satan were present and so you
know Satan's told the whole world that
same story but he leaves out the
important part it's that Jesus was going
to save you from your sin right not NE
neily the oppression of the day so it's
interesting to me that he's bowing down
to that right yeah to Mary and the
supposed baby Jesus now is that both
popes right there that is Pope Francis
and Pope the one before him Benedict
right yeah wow that's when he was
changing offices and Benedict Was um
going down uh out of office and he was
coming to office and um they were
supposedly having a private meeting and
they were bowing to the black Madonna
which in Voodoo her name is ESS Dante
Danto she's the darker she's from the
black the black uh side and this is my
book uh and my website address where you
can purchase my book and uh I changed
the subtitle I originally put our
Catholics unknowingly practicing Sanu
and Voodoo I changed it to Sania and
budoo in Catholicism well that's that's
that's pretty fascinating yes I've
learned a lot since my my conversion to
Christian you know to real to Jesus yeah
amen and uh he has Set Me Free and his
word has set me free so you know that
I'm I'm never shocked at how like
patient God is and if you are a real
truth Seeker you really want to know the
truth God navigates your path and he'll
put things in front of you and and you
know even if you don't have the support
system around you it's like God just has
this really beautiful way of
orchestrating you to the truth he's
beautiful and and to get into deception
you you really do when you look back
over your story you realize how much you
yourself have blinded yourself to that
you know you you knew like yeah you know
I did you have you have an upbringing in
religion at all none so no no context of
a spirit world or anything like that you
know nothing and and see that's amazing
to me that that you know God just you
know he he saw into the very depths of
your heart he knew what you were looking
for and he said you know I'm going to
I'm going to lead you into the source of
truth and you know yeah and it started
when I was 18 but I was really looking
for him yeah amen yeah amen and I'm so
glad that I found him yeah yeah we hope
everybody gets a chance to find him yes
he's amazing I mean um you know since
that I've written two books one was is
the children's book and this book to
expose the darkness and the other one is
a children's book to reach the the lost
children in the world for with the
Gospel of Jesus Christ and so um I would
never have had that before yeah yeah
when you find the the the source of
truth and how much you know like uh what
an amazing gift that God is offering to
us you can't but to be loud with it
right you just you can't hold it in you
want to talk about it you want to get it
out you want other people to experience
that same sort of thing so exactly you
know praise God that you've you've taken
that to heart and written a book well
thank you Marisol for coming and sharing
with us thank you for for having me
showing us the differences between you
or the similarities rather between
Catholicism and and Voodoo and sharing a
piece of your story and a peace of your
life with us and we want to thank you
all for watching and joining us on LED
live make sure you give this video a
thumbs up make sure you uh uh subscribe
make sure that you share this with
somebody else so that they can learn
these things as well there are many
people who need to know these things
that we share on these programs uh don't
forget us uh we are here to put this
information out for you if you want to
donate and help support what we're doing
you can do that uh by going to
ls. give or
patreon.com Light Studios so thank you
for joining us today and we will see you
next week take
care do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your journey
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little like
kids it's proven that people remember
things that they see more than what they
hear lightwear believes the best way to
share your witness is to wear your
witness lightwear has all kinds of
graphic te's that are a great attention
grabbing way to share the gospel so head
on over to lightwear do shop and check
out all the cool graphic te's what do
you want people to remember when they
see you
[Music]
oh